Hai dan selamat datang kembali di seri kursus Variational Quantum Eigensolver.
Nama saya Victoria Lipinska dan di video ini kita akan menyelami cara merepresentasikan
masalah VQE tertentu dengan cara yang bisa dipahami komputer kuantum.
Biasanya, masalah kimia kuantum dinyatakan dalam bentuk energi
dari sistem tersebut.
Kita menyebut operator yang menggambarkan energi-energi ini sebagai Hamiltonian.
Pertama, kita perlu mengkuantisasinya.
Artinya, menyatakannya dalam bahasa kimia kuantum,
yang secara formal disebut kuantisasi kedua.
Kalau Hamiltonian menggambarkan interaksi fermion, misalnya,
energi elektron dalam orbital spin, kita menyebutnya
sebagai Hamiltonian fermionik, dan ini akan jadi titik awal kita hari ini.
Qubit, bagaimanapun, punya bahasanya sendiri.
Operator-operator dalam dunia qubit digambarkan oleh operator Pauli.
Jadi fokus kita di sini adalah menyatakan operator fermionik
dalam bentuk operator qubit.
Ada korespondensi satu-ke-satu yang sederhana antara
keadaan nol dan satu untuk fermion dan qubit.
Jadi pemetaan antara keadaan-keadaannya pun cukup mudah.
Namun, pemetaan operatornya sedikit lebih rumit.
Tapi Hamiltonian fermionik dinyatakan dengan operator kreasi dan
anihilasi.
Jadi tugas kita adalah membuat komputer kuantum lebih mudah memahami
Hamiltonian.
Kita akan menggunakan alat matematis untuk memetakan Hamiltonian fermionik
ke Hamiltonian qubit dengan gate.
Jadi dengan kata lain, kita akan menerjemahkan antara
bahasa kimia kuantum dan bahasa komputasi kuantum.
Bayangkan dua rantai, satu dengan fermion,
yaitu bahasa kimia kuantum.
Dan satu lagi dengan qubit, yaitu bahasa komputasi kuantum.
Sekilas, pemetaannya terlihat mudah, kan?
Dalam kedua kasus, kita melihat sistem dengan dua level.
Untuk fermion, kita punya satu fermion dalam keadaan tersebut
atau tidak ada fermion sama sekali.
Dan untuk qubit, kita punya keadaan 0 atau keadaan 1.
Tapi ternyata lebih rumit dari itu.
Perbedaan antara rantai qubit dan rantai fermion
adalah sesuatu yang sangat mendasar dalam fisika: yang kita sebut simetri pertukaran.
Dua fermion tidak pernah bisa menempati keadaan yang sama.
Tapi untuk rantai qubit, ini sama sekali berbeda.
Dua qubit bisa berada dalam keadaan yang sama,
karena qubit bukan fermion.
Kita sekarang harus menemukan cara untuk menerjemahkan antara dua rantai tersebut.
Sudah sejak 1928, dua peneliti, Jordan dan Wigner,
menunjukkan bahwa operator fermionik untuk seluruh rantai
bisa direpresentasikan secara tepat dalam bentuk operator qubit.
Ini adalah pemetaan yang paling mudah untuk komputer kuantum.
Misalnya, kita bisa menggunakannya untuk memetakan okupansi
sebuah orbital ke spin satu qubit.
Secara praktis, pemetaan ini untuk Hamiltonian menghasilkan jumlah berbobot dari operator Pauli.
Ini adalah fakta yang sangat penting, yang ingin saya minta kamu ingat,
dan kita akan kembali ke ini di modul berikutnya di mana kita akan membahas
bagaimana circuit variasional dieksekusi di komputer kuantum.
Pemetaan di atas berarti kalau kita punya, misalnya,
14 operator fermionik, kita akan memetakan masalah tersebut ke 14 qubit.
Untungnya, ada cara-cara cerdas untuk mengurangi jumlah qubit
dan menggunakan lebih sedikit sumber daya kuantum untuk mendapat performa lebih baik dari komputer kuantum.
Biasanya, dalam sistem molekuler, kita akan mengetahui
beberapa simetri fisika dari Hamiltonian,
misalnya, total jumlah elektron bersifat tetap.
Informasi ini bisa digunakan untuk memperkecil ukuran masalah
tanpa kehilangan informasi yang relevan.
Teknik ini kita sebut reduksi ruang aktif.
Ini memungkinkan pengurangan jumlah sumber daya, yaitu jumlah qubit,
sebelum pemetaan qubit seperti transformasi Jordan-Wigner.
Langkah ini menghitung Hamiltonian efektif
dan memungkinkan kita menggunakan lebih sedikit qubit sebagai hasilnya.
Untuk contoh kita dengan 14 orbital,
teknik ini mengurangi jumlah qubit menjadi hanya enam.
Kita sekarang bisa melangkah lebih jauh dengan pengurangan-pengurangan ini.
Kita bisa menggunakan pemetaan yang berbeda,
yang sedikit lebih rumit dari Jordan-Wigner.
Contoh yang paling umum adalah pemetaan paritas.
Pemetaan paritas tidak memetakan okupansi orbital pada qubit,
melainkan paritas orbital ke qubit tunggal.
Kita tidak akan masuk ke detail matematisnya di sini,
tapi yang penting untuk diketahui adalah pemetaan ini mengandung
redundansi tambahan yang bisa dimanfaatkan untuk menghapus dua qubit lagi.
Jadi, contoh kita dengan 14 orbital berkurang dari 14 qubit
menjadi 6 qubit dengan reduksi ruang aktif, lalu menjadi 4 qubit
dengan pengurangan dua qubit dalam pemetaan paritas.
Mari kita sebutkan sebentar satu transformasi lagi.
Pemetaan lain yang umum digunakan antara representasi fermionik
dan qubit adalah transformasi Bravyi-Kitaev.
Transformasi Bravyi-Kitaev menggunakan qubit untuk mengkodekan informasi
tentang nomor okupansi maupun paritas keadaan kuantum.
Transformasi Bravyi-Kitaev menggabungkan informasi nomor okupansi dan paritas
untuk basis orbital molekuler berukuran N,
di sini digunakan lagi N qubit.
Namun, informasi yang tersimpan dalam setiap qubit
kini bervariasi tergantung qubit mana itu.
Yaitu ketika indeks qubit genap,
ia menyimpan nomor okupansi dari
orbital yang bersesuaian seperti dalam pemetaan Jordan-Wigner.
Ketika indeks qubit ganjil, qubit menyimpan paritas dari
sekumpulan nomor okupansi tertentu. Transformasi Bravyi-Kitaev paling efisien
ketika jumlah qubit mendekati pangkat dua.
Pemetaan Bravyi-Kitaev menggabungkan keunggulan dari Jordan-Wigner
dan transformasi paritas.
Ini mengurangi jumlah qubit yang ditindaki setiap suku Hamiltonian,
Ini penting untuk simulasi kuantum karena suku-suku yang
beraksi pada banyak qubit dalam Hamiltonian
membutuhkan circuit yang lebih panjang untuk simulasinya.
Ini berarti kedalaman circuit
berkurang dengan transformasi Bravyi-Kitaev dan secara umum
kita bisa mendapatkan hasil yang lebih baik dengan hardware.
Ini adalah peningkatan dibanding transformasi Jordan-Wigner
yang menghasilkan Hamiltonian qubit orde N.
Jadi, di video ini kita mengeksplorasi metode-metode untuk memetakan
Hamiltonian fermionik ke Hamiltonian qubit.
Di video berikutnya kita akan lihat cara terbaik memilih keadaan
dan bentuk variasional atau sebuah circuit.
Sampai jumpa di sana.